you go to order a meal and you have two
choices for an appetizer three choices
for an entree four choices for dessert
how many different meals can you have if
you choose one appetizer one entree and
one dessert okay so the reason they call
us multiplication counting principle
I'll show you why that is one way to
look at this is to make a tree diagram
so you have three choices actually I'm
sorry two choices for an appetizer so
it'd be like this you can either go down
this route or this route right then once
you pick your appetizer you've got three
choices for an entree so you could say
okay I'm gonna pick one two or three one
two or three depending on which route
you go right then you've got four
choices for dessert so you could go 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2
3 4 right so it's kind of like a
choose-your-own-adventure you can either
go down any of these branches and you're
going to end up at one of these end
points over here right but you can see
that if you have a lot of choices this
could quickly grow into a gigantic tree
it would take you a long time to draw it
all out etc so the short cut is what you
do is you look at each level here and
you say you know how many choices are
there at each level well you can see
I've got two choices for the appetizer
three choices for the entree four
choices for the dessert if I multiply
those out you can see I'm getting 24
which is the same number of end points
we have here if we were to count all
these 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 add all those up
we're gonna get 24 but this is a lot
quicker just multiply them together okay
let's go through another example but
before I do that this concept here this
multiplication counting principle or the
fundamental counting principle is
something you want to know for the AC T
and the SAT so if you're preparing for
those two tasks and you want to
additional help preparing you like my
teaching style check out my huge AC T
math review video course and my huge SAT
math review video of course we go
through a number of different concepts
with explanations sample problems
opportunities for you to practice going
over those key concepts that the makers
of those tests want you to understand
want you to know so definitely something
to to check out take a look at the three
free previews I've got three free
previews for each course so you can take
a look at those and those
whew and then you can go on and get the
course from there so I'll have a link in
the description for that let's go to
example number two though it says how
many words containing three letters can
you make out of the letters in the word
math right assuming that letters cannot
be repeated okay so another way to look
at this is like you know imagine if you
had these letters in a hat right so
here's M a T and H right and so you're
gonna pick these letters out of a hat so
just imagine you're reaching in there
all different letters okay so you just
reach and you say well how many ways can
I pick that first letter right so I'm
trying to make a three letter word and
you can see well I've got four choices
so that's going to be four once I pick
that letter right I can't use it again
because it says it can't be repeated so
how many choices are then for the next
letter
well you're gonna see there's going
three choices for that next ladder right
and then when you go to reach for that
third letter how many choices are left
well there's only going to be two left
so now if you multiply those together
you can see there's going to be 24 and
so there's 24 different words that you
could make three letter words with the
letters ma th so this happened to be a
coincidence that they came out to the
same you know number but that's how you
would work with it so look at how many
choices there are at each you know and
then multiply them together